[Music]
on this tuesday night ukraine urges calm
as the rhetoric ramps up
the u.s sends military equipment to
ukraine and warns russia of enormous
consequences if it invades the largest
invasion since world war ii it would
change the world ordered out ottawa
tells families of diplomatic staff to
leave as ukrainian canadians wonder
what's next i'm worried i don't know
what's going to happen and nobody knows
what's going to happen boris johnson
fights for his political survival the
mat is now investigating
a number of events that took place at
downing street and the final destination
will the world's most powerful telescope
tell us how it all began
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the uncertainty over what
the russian president intends to do
about ukraine vladimir putin's
spokesperson is accusing the u.s of
escalating tensions saying he's
profoundly concerned the u.s has put
more than 8 000 american troops on
heightened alert russia today announced
a flurry of what it calls military
drills right across its territory
releasing these images including in
belarus near ukraine russia insists it
has no intention of invading ukraine
even though it's built up thousands of
troops near the border today u.s
president joe biden said he'd consider
imposing sanctions against vladimir
putin himself and he said there will be
enormous consequences if russia makes a
move on ukraine
if he were to move in with all those
forces to be the largest invasion since
world war ii it would change the world
biden also clarified that he has no
intention of moving u.s troops directly
to ukraine but might move them into
nearby nato countries asked whether the
risk of an invasion is increasing or
decreasing biden said assessing putin's
intentions is like reading tea leaves
our coverage begins with crystal
commencing in kiev ukraine
despite continuous calls for calm fears
that russia will invade ukraine refuse
to fade russia releasing this new
military training video tuesday
highlighting its force
meanwhile more military assets from nato
allies are making their way to eastern
europe this frigate from denmark is
headed to the baltic sea and another
american supply plane landed in kiev
stalked with military equipment and
munitions
below ground in a soviet-era bunker hand
cranks are turning once again for
protection manual air circulation is a
feature of this bomb shelter in kiev
this cold dimly lit multi-room space is
for city employees in case of an
emergency here they can do some basic
work for a few days this bunker isn't
very big but this is a map of the
underground facility and we're in this
room right here now this bunker was
first opened up in 1971
it is not very big but can hold about
210 people now you'll see there's a lot
of these posters on the walls obviously
first aid has changed over the years but
a lot of these talk about what to do in
the case of biological attack a nuclear
attack and these were actually added
these posters were added after the
chernobyl disaster
the chief of the civil protection
department says shelters like this one
can be stocked with water and food on
short notice there are many others
accessible around the city that citizens
can access and maps have been published
pinpointing their locations
alexander levy says i hope that we won't
need it but we have to have it we have
to be ready for anything the main thing
we need peace in this
world some feel the bunkers talk of war
in the auxiliary training sessions are
more for show than a sign of something
inevitable
lube of rood was a teacher in the former
soviet union and remembers instructions
for school children during the cold war
when people feared american bumps she'll
go to the basement for safety but
doesn't think it'll come to that
still people are making plans
vitaly is a reservist and has organized
papers for his family in kiev should he
need to send them out of the country for
their safety there are thousands more
preparing for the same
for now people are getting on with their
daily lives but having experienced the
2014 invasion the bloodshed that
followed and the annexation of crimea
ukrainians know anything is possible
donna
all right crystal gomezing in ukraine
tonight thanks canada is still
considering its role in all of this and
what our military is capable of offering
families of diplomats at the embassy in
ukraine and military personnel have now
been ordered out of the country our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
is looking at that angle tonight
mercedes
donna canada now says that diplomats
families must leave ukraine due to the
ongoing military buildup and what the
minister's office described as quote
destabilizing activities in and around
ukraine this follows the lead of the
united states which ordered diplomats
families to leave the u.s embassy in
kiev on sunday prime minister justin
trudeau and his cabinet are still
deliberating over what next steps they
might take to help ukraine he's expected
to make an announcement here tomorrow in
ottawa on that national security sources
say they expect ottawa and the liberal
government to approve a shipment of
hundreds of guns and ammunition for the
ukrainian military it is unclear though
if ottawa is considering ukraine's
request for more troops on operation
unifier in ukraine the government could
also choose to put more troops into the
region around ukraine by beefing up
operation reassurance which is based in
latvia and the mediterranean sea but it
could expand back out to countries like
romania where we've had a presence
before sources say that canada is not
looking to fight a war and does not
believe the small contribution of guns
and ammo to the ukrainian military is
going to make any kind of a strategic
difference but this donna really is
about a signal of support and showing
nato-wide deterrence something allies
are collaborating on the canadian
government is also bracing for the
potential of more cyber attacks from
russia according to national security
sources when those additional supports
for ukraine are announced in the coming
days another potential trigger a planned
visit for the minister of national
defense anita anand to ukraine
that certainly they think could trigger
more cyber attacks on canada donna
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks canada has the largest ukrainian
population outside of ukraine and russia
more than 1.3 million people identify as
ukrainian-canadian and many are
increasingly uneasy about the
uncertainty in their homeland mike
draulie has been speaking to some of
them
even in 2016 when maxon solya rescue had
a family reunion in kiev he couldn't
escape the feeling that russia was at
the doorstep
tensions have been simmering he says
every day since ukraine's pro-russian
government was ousted in 2014. we've
been
uh living under a pressure and under
stress for for quite uh for quite a
while now but definitely the last months
or so
i think that level of anxiety
increased tenfold russia is all
ukrainian canadians are talking about
right now toronto's a christine
eliaszewski who lives off and on in
ukraine
says the uncertainty has left many ill
at ease i'm not scared
i'm not scared but i am very very
anxious
uh i'm worried i don't know what's going
to happen and nobody knows what's going
to happen canada has a large ukrainian
population 1.4 million based on the last
census mostly in western canada and the
prairies they've been vocal in their
attempts to encourage western
governments to intervene on their behalf
but while the number of politicians who
have posted pictures with the hashtag
stand with ukraine banner creates
conversation words and pictures will
only do so much
we believe that the most effective way
to deter for the russian invasion is to
take proactive rather than reactive
steps
ukrainians are not asking anyone to
fight for them but they need our help to
defend their country against a colonial
power seeking their destruction russian
president vladimir putin has been very
clear in recent years that he believes
ukraine is fundamentally part of russia
even going so far as to call russians
and ukrainians one people he won't go
away and i think ukrainians will be
faced with uh with putin for the and
russia for the rest of their lives for
the rest of the
history until the regime changes in
russia that could make for a very cold
future microlight global news toronto
now to the pandemic the federal
government is resisting pressure from
those who want the vaccination mandate
for cross-border truck drivers scrapped
in a statement the government said since
the start of the pandemic it's been
consulting with the canadian trucking
alliance and both agree vaccines
combined with public health measures are
the most effective tool to reduce the
risk of covet 19.
a convoy of truckers and others opposed
to public health mandates are on their
way from vancouver to ottawa they call
themselves the freedom convoy it was
organized by a group called canada unity
which claims measures to reduce the
spread of covet are unlawful and it's
got the support of some prominent
conservatives
former federal leader andrew shearer
tweeted thank you truckers and called
prime minister justin trudeau the
biggest threat to freedom in canada a
gofundme page has now collected more
than 4.6 million dollars to support the
convoy though gofundme has now put a
hold on those funds until the organizer
is able to provide a clear plan on how
the money will be spent
in the uk the british prime minister
appears to be redefining the term
political party the police are now
investigating multiple gatherings held
at 10 downing street during the lockdown
including a birthday party for boris
johnson himself in june of
as redmond shannon reports it's adding
to the already intense pressure for
johnson to step down
this may not have been the only
celebration of boris johnson's birthday
in june 2020. 30 staff reportedly
gathered for an event in honor of the
british prime minister at his downing
street office too
there are now at least 16 news reports
of lockdown rules allegedly being broken
in and around downing street including a
byo party and another with a suitcase of
wine now police are involved i can
confirm
that the met is now investigating
a number of events that took place at
downing street and whitehall
in the last two years
in relation to potential breaches of
covet-19 regulations downing street says
no laws were broken but johnson's
reactions to the mounting news reports
keep changing from denial all the
guidelines were observed to contrition
mr speaker i want to apologize and now
acceptance so i welcome the mets
decision to conduct its own
investigation a civil service inquiry
into events is expected to report back
this week potentially triggering an
attempt from johnson's tory mps to
topple him frankly cannot believe that
this man is still the head of our
government
um and
you know our representative on the
international stage amis waldman's
grandmother sheila died of covin 19. the
family had to attend the funeral over
zoom it just makes you so angry and
exasperated and tired just exhausted by
it all
because it's just prolonged everyone's
pain it's no surprise that this entire
saga has been hugely damaging to
johnson's conservatives in the polls
donna
okay redmond shannon in london thanks
another devastating discovery in bc
coming up the results of a nine month
investigation at a former residential
school
[Music]
there's been another confirmation of
unmarred graves at a residential school
in canada williams lake first nation in
bc says an initial ground radar search
found evidence of what could be 93
unmarked graves they're near the former
site of the saint joseph's mission
residential school thousands of
indigenous children were forced to
attend some
never went home heather urix west
reports and a warning there are
disturbing details in her story
i want to just take time to
to do a moment silence for those
children
that are missing it began with a moment
of quiet reflection as members of
williams lake first nation gathered to
share preliminary results of a nine
month long investigation
for chief willie sellers the results
were painful to share our team has
recorded not only stories involving the
murder and disappearance of children and
infants
they have listened to countless stories
of systemic tor systematic torture
starvation
rape and sexual assault of children at
st joseph's mission
examination of the site of the school
and the surrounding grounds revealed
children are indeed buried there to date
93 reflections have been recorded at the
saint joseph's mission
all of them display varying
characteristics indicative of potential
human burials the saint joseph's mission
residential school no longer stands near
williams lake but for nearly 100 years
it was the site of so much heartache
phyllis webstad was among the many
children forced to attend her story of
loss as a six-year-old here in 1973
inspired a national day to learn and
remember my granny bought me a shiny new
orange shirt to go to school in when i
got there i was stripped my clothing
taken away including my new orange shirt
in a statement websted called the
confirmation of children's remains found
at the mission traumatizing but also
validation of the stories told williams
lake first nation launched its search on
the grounds of saint joseph's after the
to come loops disequip first station
revealed that the remains of 215
children have been discovered by a radar
search of the former indian residential
school site in kamloops british columbia
other discoveries would follow including
the unmarked graves of more than 700
people near the maryvale residential
school on the kawasa's first nation in
saskatchewan discoveries that have
prompted a national reckoning over the
country's treatment of indigenous
children both then and now we cannot
afford to have another generation grow
up without understanding the truth of
the residential school system and the
impact it has had on first nations
people
we need to heal the williams lake first
nation says the investigation here is
far from done but they've committed to
continue working to bring every bit of
this community's dark chapter into the
light where healing can begin
heather urex west global news calgary
there is some support for those affected
by this the 24-hour crisis line is
available the number is toll-free you
can speak in confidence it's
1-800-721-0066
turning memes into money ahead how
social media has changed the stock
market game
[Music]
the pandemic has been a tumultuous time
for global stock markets we've seen
peaks and valleys that not many could
have predicted one thing has become
increasingly clear the way people invest
is changing in the final installment of
our influenced series ann gaviola
explains how cobit 19 and social media
combine to impact the markets in a major
way
rory nickel never really picked stocks
before the pandemic but coveted
restrictions extra cash and free time
factored into his new obsession
especially meme stocks which were all
the rage on reddit and twitter i got
caught into the hype of
not only was it like a way to make money
but it felt like
there was a community of us coming
together according to new data shared
exclusively with global news by british
columbia's securities regulator more
than a third of canadians are getting
investment information from social media
and online forums at least once a week
facebook is the fourth most popular
source after news articles tv and radio
online forums and social media are such
popular places for stock discussions and
investment scams that regulators are
targeting them from subreddits like bay
street bets to platforms like kijiji and
craigslist
the ontario securities commission says
social media creates digital echo
chambers where investment risks aren't
always clearly communicated people have
um investment thesis and it gets
reinforced over and over again
by people who are
have a similar mind about
about the value of those assets
i think that's very similar to
what we've seen in um in in social media
generally the bc securities regulator
says stock talk on social media skews
male and young take some time
to think about the information
who's giving you the information might
it be exaggerated or misleading
potentially fraudulent market analysts
say keeping tabs on the stock market now
includes keeping on top of social media
right now it is the wild west and at
some point it's going to be rained in
jeff gadway put some money into mean
stocks as an experiment when you see
these you know herds of people rushing
towards
what seemed to be easy money
opportunities
i think it creates a lot of fomo we know
social media does that he lost money
after the 2021 gamestop surge that made
international headlines but says he came
away with some valuable lessons
ann gaviola global news toronto
next unraveling the mysteries of our
universe thanks to a massive new
telescope
after decades of preparations the james
webb telescope has finally reached its
sweet spot in outer space the 10 billion
dollar project is the world's largest
and most powerful telescope ever
deployed eric sorensen explains what
it's searching for and the crucial role
canada played in its creation
decollage liftoff after 30 years of
preparation it's been a nerve-wracking
29 days separation web space telescope
the james webb space telescope zoomed
from earth to a place one and a half
million kilometers away all the while
fine-tuning stretching out its tennis
court-sized solar shield and unfolding
its giant mirror we're now at our
orbital destination and soon enough be
able to make amazing discoveries webb
has parked in a perfect location
shielded from the heat and light of the
sun at 85 degrees celsius on the hot
side the instruments would not have
lasted but on the cold side at minus 233
celsius webb can work for years in the
dark its infrared cameras will gaze deep
into the universe james webb is going to
follow the earth around canadian
astronomer lisa deng will be among the
first to use webb to study a distant
exoplanet with oceans of lava and a rock
vapor atmosphere that could reveal life
elsewhere in the universe first we're
looking at the constituents of the of
the atmosphere of a lot of planets what
are the processes that are making these
constituents is it life and if it is
then how are we going to move forward
and detect this life canada is a major
partner with nasa and the european space
agency building an imager to probe those
far away planets and a guidance sensor
to focus on the most distant galaxies
that will take us closer to the big bang
the webb telescope will gather light
peering back more than 13 billion years
to help understand how it all began
that's when the modern structure of the
universe was you know the template was
being laid down web is going to be able
to show us how those stars formed and
how those galaxies and galaxy clusters
were forming right back there at the
beginning of time that will be huge the
mirrors will be tweaked for months the
first clear images should be visible in
june it all culminates 20 years of work
for one canadian astronomer and the best
is still to come i'm on the team that's
looking at the the baby galaxies and
then the growth of galaxies all of us
right here at st mary's are super
excited one added bonus webb didn't need
as much fuel as planned for the flight
so it will have more fuel to operate
well beyond its 10-year lifetime
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is mississauga ontario thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye
[Applause]
[Music]